amer is next in Los Angeles I got mayor
who are you hey Dave how it's a pleasure
speaking with you you too what's up I'm
calling on behalf of my parents I think
the thing to show for a long time I
noticed my parents are living a little
bit differently and I'm just want to
know if how I can help them so they they
really believe in having a credit score
so they spend everything every month on
a credit card and they always paid off
so for 20 years they've never had any
over charges they've never had any late
payments or any interest payments but
they really believe having a credit
score is valuable in this country how do
i how do I get them off of that idea how
old are you I am 21 you're not you know
you're not gonna get them off the idea
okay they've been doing this since
before you were born they don't want
your opinion we call it the powdered
butt syndrome once someone is powdered
your butt they don't want your opinion
about money or sex and so the chances of
mom and dad listening to a 21 the
chances of mom and dad listening to a 21
year old preach to them about how to
handle their money is almost zero unless
they ask and now what you can do is a
couple of things one I mean you're not
gonna be able to sit down and have a
one-on-one debate with your dad and him
suddenly stop doing what he's been doing
since before you were born
you follow me you just don't have
credibility to do that but you can tell
them about your story they're gonna
disagree they're not gonna like your
story you're living without a credit
score you're living on a cash basis
you're not going into debt so that you
can go into debt so that you can go into
debt so that you can go into debt which
is the credit score dog chasing its tail
that the whole culture lives with I'm
going into debt why so that I can go
into debt why so that I can go into that
why so then go into that and that's what
your dad has done his whole life and
he's you know he thinks that FICO is his
provider and FICO is not his provider
wealth is his provider
and the good job he's probably done a
good job with money it sounds like
they're very disciplined and that
they've used the as you said moving to
this country they've used that as an
opportunity and I suspect they built
some wealth yeah my second question is
that my dad's looking to buy a second
home or to give us a rental property
income because my dad doesn't have a any
kind of investment or 401k and since he
yourself he works on his own my mom has
a small 401k from her work but it's only
twenty five thousand in there but my dad
has nothing except like his nest egg
which he wants to buy a property with
debt to rent out for income is that
should I should I try to encourage him
to also put some of that into investing
and then use the rest of it for that or
yeah I would avoid a rental property
with that I don't tell people to do that
and I would tell him to first build his
Roth IRA and your mom's Roth IRA in some
good growth stock mutual funds so bottom
line is they haven't built wealth I was
wrong I thought they had but they're
basically broke because they've been
worshipping at the altar of the great
FICO so number one tell them your story
number two you could give them a copy of
our book introduce them to the idea let
someone else talk to them about it I
doubt they're gonna take your advice it
would be unusual for them to do so